I figured out a way to implement this
change in only the index.html file
remember that's where the templates are
stored now I haven't used backbone a ton
and there wasn't an answer waiting for
me so I had to figure it out myself let
me go through my thought process the
first thing I noticed is when we check a
box something actually happens here
where is the code that makes that happen
I asked myself well I remembered that
each one of these is rendered based off
of a template and that template is here
in the HTML file so I scroll down and
found it and sure enough right here is
the input the check box and it says
input class equals toggle type equals
checkbox and then this weird thing so
what the heck is that it turns out this
is the way the template conditionally
adds things this here is interpreted
logically it's not just normal HTML it's
actually interpreted by backbone and it
says completed ? checked or empty so if
completed is true then add the checked
attribute otherwise add no attribute now
what I wanted to do is I wanted to add a
done text to the end of the title so I
figured this looks like the title right
here I could probably just do the same
thing here right here so when completed
is true we want to spit out checked
let's save that and go into our browser
and see what that looks like if I hit
refresh you'll see that it says run the
application checked explore the file
structure checked modify our application
nothing's here but if I click the check
bark sure enough checked now that's not
exactly what I wanted it to do I want it
instead to add the text dash dash done
let me save that and go and refresh and
sure enough dash dash done so I tested
it it worked and then I went back and I
added an exclamation point because I was
really excited so that really was only a
couple steps first I noticed that
something changed when we checked the
box and that's what I wanted to change
I found the code that made that happen
in the item template in our HTML and I
looked at the syntax that was making
this happen and I basically copied it
changed it up a teeny bit tested it it
worked and then I added the exclamation
board so that was pretty simple and it's
because I've done this before not this
problem but I've gotten code that is not
my code and I've how to find a way to
integrate my changes and ultimately it's
the practice that helps we aren't
learning to solve individual problems
anymore we're altima tlie learning how
to be a detective well a tofu detective
actually one who can track down where
the change should be made and then
integrate seamlessly into the code
that's already there